and Arizona prosecutor will play a
significant part in today's hearing
Senate Republicans asked Rachel Mitchell
to a question professor Blasi Ford and
judge Cavanaugh she's head of the sex
crimes unit for the fourth most
populated county in America yet O'Keefe
is outside the hearing room on Capitol
Hill Edie how do we expect this
prosecutor to impact the tone of the
hearing she could have a big impact on
things John she's a veteran prosecutor
Republican and head of the Special
Victims Division in Maricopa County in
Arizona she's been on the job since 1993
and oversees a team of attorneys and
detectives who handle sexual misconduct
and child molestation cases Senate
Judiciary Committee chairman chuck
Grassley hired her on Tuesday and she
essentially allows the 11 Republican
members of the Judiciary Committee all
of whom are men to take a pass on
directly questioning Ford avoiding
potentially awkward optics Louisiana
Senator John Kennedy who met with
Mitchell yesterday says she's been hired
because she's had an extraordinary
reputation for being able to ferret out
the truth we have no plans whatsoever to
try to have any gotcha moment sir
go Catwoman or Batman on anybody I mean
the purpose of this is to allow dr. Ford
and judge Cavanaugh to tell their story
another Republican member of the
committee who met with Mitchell
yesterday told me privately that he
found Mitchell to be quote reassuring in
the sense that she'll handle it properly
treat the accuser with respect and ask
pertinent questions now it is
exceedingly rare for anybody other than
a lawmaker to ask questions at a
congressional hearing last like this the
last time something like this happened
we've been all the way back in 1998 when
the House Judiciary Committee held
impeachment proceedings against then
President Bill Clinton Gale all right
and we could hear you loud and clear a
lot of a lot of TV stations are going
live this morning so we could hear
somebody else's live shot but we heard
you ad we heard you Ed O'Keefe thank you
very much